Democrats go back to defending Al
Franken the media continued to push
Republicans to declare president Trump
racist and Iran escalates I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show oh
[Music]
man I hope you had a wonderful weekend a
news packed weekend as it turns out when
we begin this morning with this insane
contention from The New Yorker and Jane
Mayer so Jane Mayer you'll recall is the
reporter from The New Yorker who went
after Brett Kavanaugh she reported the
story of Deborah Ramirez who has
apparently drunk offer drunk as a skunk
and claimed that Kavanaugh when he was
back in college flashed himself to her
and it took her days on end to think
about it and then determine that it
actually was Brett Kavanaugh there were
no other witnesses nobody else could say
that it was Brett Kavanaugh Jane Mayer
reported this with a straight face over
at The New Yorker because Brett
Kavanaugh was a bad bad bad man
well now Jane Mayer is out there trying
to rehabilitate Al Franken now what's so
fascinating about this is that there was
a question with regard to the left and
this question I think is deeply
important as to whether the left abides
many in the media left particularly
abide by their own principles this
becomes very important when it comes to
assessing how American parties and
politicians and and how Americans
themselves are reacting to one another
see here's the thing if you want to set
a common standard within a circle of
trust it's not very difficult now you go
to your church and you say listen all of
us were against X and you're all
invested in being against next because
you know you share this this group of
common principles but that changes if
for example you're in a sporting event
so let's take the example of the
sporting event because politics has now
become more like sports and less like us
as a common group trying to find some
future together in a sporting event
let's say that you're a player in a
sporting event and the guy on the other
side is cheating so you have two choices
one is you can be as honest as the day
is long you can you can say well you
know that guy's gonna cheat but I'm
gonna play the game the right way now
that is indeed the right thing to do it
also heightens the chances that you're
gonna lose because presumably the person
wouldn't be cheating unless it was
heightening their chances of winning so
what you end up with in sports when it
comes to cheating is a sort of
prisoner's dilemma so for folks who
don't know what a prisoner's dilemma is
a little bit of basic game theory for
you so the prisoner's dilemma is based
on a situation in
the police arrest a couple of suspects
in a crime and they say to suspect
number one here's the deal if you rat on
your friend we let you off we convict
your friend if you do not rat on your
friend and your friend rats on you
you're gonna go to jail for 10 years and
your friend goes free if neither of you
rat and you're both gonna go to jail for
two years if both of you rat then you
end up both going to jail for like five
years right so that it's a little bit
complex right so you have to think of
the stakes here are you gonna rat on
your friend you're not gonna rat on your
friend so if you trust your friend you
don't rat because if neither of you rat
then you're both gonna go to jail for it
maybe a couple of years but that is
better presumably then every other
scenario except for the scenario where
you rat and your friend doesn't right so
the best option here is for you to cheat
just on a personal level the best option
is for you to rat out your friend and
your friend that sucker doesn't rat on
you and he ends up with the entire 10
year sentence and you go free but if you
rat on each other you end up with five
years so the question becomes how much
do you trust your partner in crime well
when it comes to politics where it's
adversarial from the outset or in the
sporting event that I'm talking about
where it's adversarial from the outset
the other guy cheats and your best
option is not going to be to allow him
to cheat and you don't cheat that is the
equivalence in the prisoner's dilemma of
the other guy ratting on you and you
saying nothing and you going to jail for
10 years well in politics when it comes
to standards and upholding standards the
moral right thing to do is to uphold the
standard but politics of course are not
just about doing it the moral right
thing unfortunately politics are very
often about winning and achieving a
higher goal and achieving a secondary
goal and wielding power and so the
question becomes are you going to allow
the other side to not abide by a
standard while you stand there abiding
by the standard or are you also going to
say listen I'm not giving you guys an
inch I'll just lie I'll just pretend
that I uphold the standard when I don't
the same way that you pretend you uphold
the standard when you don't the only way
that you can have a political situation
in which both sides condemn something
bad is when there's an agreed-upon set
of rules and punishments for violating
the rules however if there is a feeling
by either side that the rules can be
violated with impunity by the other side
then you're not going to abide by the
rules because why would you then you're
the sucker in this prisoner's dilemma
you're the sucker in this game and that
is what we are seeing right now in
American politics is people on Bo
the right and the left the mostly on the
left lying about the standards that they
actually uphold when it comes to
behavior by politicians particularly
when it comes to rhetoric when it comes
to the standards that we should share as
Americans the way that it works is that
if somebody on the Left does something
very bad then the left simply looks past
it just right past it and then if
somebody on the right does something bad
then suddenly the standard kicks in full
force and they are very much in favor of
the standard and they are standing for
the standard how dare you not stand for
the standard and so what a lot of
conservatives are doing is they're
responding a lot of Republicans they're
responding by saying you're treating so
I'm gonna cheat you don't hold your
standard and I'm not gonna pretend you
hold your standard so why should I abide
by that standard either and then lose in
the process now all of this makes
American politics uglier and the only
way to solve this is to rebuild a system
of trust whereby both sides
end up condemning folks within their
midst the problem is it's gonna be very
difficult to do that because the stakes
are now so high politically as the
parties move the right to the right and
the left to the left as both of these
parties expose this gap in the middle of
American politics what you end up with
is the argument that in the end doesn't
really matter if we violate our
standards so long as we do something
more important for the broad span of the
American public isn't it more important
that we get things done even if it means
that we bend the rules a little bit well
see how this plays out in just a second
with regard to jane mayer and al franken
first a rising geopolitical tensions
have led to five-year highs in gold
prices that is not a shock Iran is
getting extraordinarily militant we'll
get to that a little bit later on in the
show they've now announced they will
break the uranium stockpile limit they
agreed to under the nuclear deal shocked
coincidence the gold prices have been
steadily rising since the tanker
bombings of course not because as I've
been telling you for the past four years
gold is a safe haven against uncertainty
is it part of your plan it should be has
you dense inflation hedge against
uncertainty and instability with
precious metals my savings plan is
diversified and yours should be as well
the company I trust with precious metal
purchases is Birch gold group look back
historically when the bottom falls out
of everything else gold tends to
safeguard savings Birch gold group has
thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews and a plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
so go contact Birch gold group right now
get a free information kit on physical
precious metals the folks I trust the
precious metals purchases and you should
sue the really good people see if
diversifying into gold and silver
sense for you they have a comprehensive
16 page kit showing how gold and silver
can protect your savings they can move
your IRA or 401k out of stocks and bonds
into a precious metals IRA if that is
something you are looking for to get
that no-cost no-obligation kit text Ben
- 47 47 47 again text been my name - 47
47 47 go check them out right now okay
so the Jay Mayer example today she has a
long piece in The New Yorker called the
case of Al Franken now to review how we
got to the point where Al Franken
resigned from the Senate
you have to understand that there was an
open debate as to whether Democrats were
being sincere in their condemnation of
Al Franken so in the late 1990s the
entire Democratic Party bends over
backwards for Bill Clinton who is
sexually harassing the help and who was
and who was sexually abusing allegedly a
variety of women many women came forward
with serious sexual allegations ranging
from Juanita broderick to Kathleen
Willey to Paula Jones all of them backed
by some level of evidence and the
Democratic Party basically looked the
other way the Democratic Party and
members of the media they said as long
as he is giving us what we want
politically we are not going to undercut
the President of the United States even
if it turns out that he committed
perjury and was mistreating women
dramatically over the course of his
career and the right originally took the
stance okay well were condemning that
and now we are going to and and now
we're gonna uphold our standard right
this is what george w bush ran as george
w bush ran with the idea that he was
gonna restore honor and dignity to the
Oval Office it's why Al Gore didn't
campaign openly with Bill Clinton in
2000 because the Republican Party was
saying listen here's Clinton and he's a
he's a hound and he's terrible to women
he's a liar and we need to restore some
sort of integrity to the Oval Office
okay fine so the Republican Party at
this point has not defected it's called
defecting and the prisoners dilemma when
you when you decide that you're going to
rat on your friend so the right has not
yet affected the left has already
defected and so far so good because it
turns out George W Bush wins the
election then in 2008 the left wins the
presidency and not only do they win the
presidency but they begin to excuse
every sort of behavior that they can
find not with regard to sexual
harassment per se but with regard to for
example racial issues any sort of any
sort of racial issue they decide they're
going to play up to the hilt and this
becomes
we'll get to that in just a second but
when it comes to the sexual assault sort
of stuff
in 2008 the Democrats win in 2012 the
Democrats win and Republicans are
getting increasingly frustrated they
feel that they've been given a non fair
shake by the media that they've never
been given credit for doing the right
thing that they've been called bearer
clingers and deplorable z' they feel
that in 2012 Mitt Romney was mislabeled
and maligned as a sexist and a racist
and so he gets a 2016 and the
Republicans finally say you know what
now we're gonna cheat because as it
turns out we can't win the Honorable way
you guys defected back in 1998 so now
we're going to defect and if Donald
Trump has said or done bad things with
women well we're just gonna look the
other way on that and so now you have
that prisoner's dilemma where everybody
ends up with five years in prison
because now both Sarge both sides aren't
defecting both sides have said that the
standard doesn't matter and this is when
the Democratic Party decides that
they're going to make a move and the
question is whether this move is a
sincere attempt to rebuild American
trust or whether they are once again
using the standard in an attempt to
re-implement a standard they originally
broke in order to go get Republicans so
now you have a situation where the
Democratic Party has Al Franken on its
hands and they don't like Donald Trump
they think that Donald Trump is very bad
but it's a little bit too late for them
to put this genie back in the bottle
because Bill Clinton everybody and
Hillary Clinton had just been their
nominee in 2016 when she of course had
looked yet not only looked the other way
but ardently defended Bill Clinton in
the face of all the meats who sort of
allegations against Bill Clinton so the
Democratic Party decides that they are
going to reinstitute the standard now
they're going to be the party of
morality and decency and so in the
pursuit of portraying themselves as such
they decide that they are going to oust
Al Franken so they're a bunch of
allegations against Al Franken most of
them none of them are a violent sexual
assault but they're there's an
allegation that he was Munn that he was
mimicking grabbing groping a woman Leon
Sweden aboard a flight a military flight
and there's a picture from doing it
there are allegations by a vast bevy of
women who say that Al Franken on
campaign stops was gripping them by the
ass in the middle of the campaign stop
and Al Franken is forced to resign and
leading the charge on that is senator
Kirsten Gillibrand so Kristin Gillibrand
says Al Franken should go and a bunch of
other Democratic senators say Al Franken
should go now the reason that they say
that they think Al Franken should go the
question is are they doing this
sincerely because they have real
during the me2 moments but this stuff is
very very bad or is this all Democrats
trying to now reestablish a standard
after Republicans have supposedly
defected right now are they trying to
reestablish the standard against their
own side just so they can go after
Republicans now the motivation for that
doesn't end up mattering all that much
in the practical sphere if Democrats
hold to it it's actually a good thing
right if Democrats decide what we're
going to do now is we're going to shame
Republicans into acting better and into
condemning their own by condemning our
own that's actually not a bad thing for
the American public discourse it's
actually quite a good thing when people
condemn bad activity on their own side
but now it appears as Jane Mayer points
out at The New Yorker that none of this
was real in the first place and you
wonder why Republicans are not
interested in going back to the old
rules you wonder why Republicans are
willing to look the other way when
president Trump does bad stuff or when
their allegations the president Trump
has mistreated people it's because they
don't trust that the Democrats are still
not cheating right Democrats keep saying
no we're reestablishing the rules
we're being decent again we're not
ratting on you anymore in the prisoner's
dilemma now we're trying to rebuild that
circle of trust we have the same
principles and then as soon as it
becomes politically convenient then all
of a sudden right after after throwing
Bill Clinton a little bit under the bus
and after throwing Al Franken under the
bus it's only been a couple of years
after that they come back and they say
you know what see we're a tenant we're
kind of lying right it was it was all a
ruse so here's Jim Maher in The New
Yorker
talking about Al Franken she says last
month in Minneapolis I climbed the
stairs of a row house to find al franken
Minnesota's disgraced former senator
wandering around in jeans and stocking
feet it was a sunny day but the shades
were mostly drawn takeout containers of
coos and carrot sticks were set out on
the kitchen table his wife Franny Bryson
was stuck in their apartment in
Washington DC with the cold he had
evidently done the best he could to be
hospitable but the place felt like a
kind of man cave or someone hides out
from the world which is more or less
what Franken has been doing since he
resigned in December 2017 amid
accusations of sexual impropriety when
she talks about what a terrible life al
franken has he was talked up as a
possible challenger to Donald Trump in
he was an effective critic of the Trump
administration but then she says as it
turns out frankenz only role in the 2020
presidential campaign has been as a
figure of controversy on June 4th the
Buddha judge was widely criticized on
social media for saying he would not
have pressured Franken to resign
I said virtually all his Democratic
rivals were then in the Senate without
first learning more about the alleged
incidents at the same time the
presidential candidacy of senator
Kirsten Gillibrand had been plagued by
questions about her role as the first of
three dozen Democratic senators to
demand Franklin's resignation
Gillibrand has cast herself as a
feminist champion of zero tolerance
toward sexual impropriety but democratic
donors sympathetic to Franken have
stunted her fundraising and Gillibrand
says tried to intimidate her into
silence okay so all of this is a
build-up to the Democrats violating
their newfound standards who remember
the Democrats the question was were they
doing this sincerely were they throwing
Al Franken out of the Senate because
they suddenly had had a change of heart
and they sincerely wanted to set a
standard whereby male impropriety was
going to be punished or was this all a
fake just to get Donald Trump or to get
for example Brett Kavanaugh the jane
mayer piece is pretty damn good evidence
that it was all fake and an attempt to
just get Donald Trump and Brett kavanah
why well Jane Mayer number one wrote all
of these hit pieces as I said unjustice
Cavanaugh suggesting without any real
evidence that he had sexually harassed a
woman or abused a woman by exposing
himself to her back in college even
though there were no witnesses well now
she's got a full piece in New York or
talking about how Al Franken is the real
victim and how the accusations against
him are really evidence less the reason
this is important is because again it
goes to the heart of the mistrust that
is seething that is tearing away at the
core of our politics Republicans are
rightly pointing at jane mayer and
rightly pointing at Democrats who five
minutes ago were the ones who else did
Al Franken and saying yeah you guys were
full of it it was all I didn't want to
ask al franken all you really wanted to
do was trade Al Franken you're trading a
night for a queen all you were trying to
do was ousted Franken so they could you
could then use your new found political
principles in order to go after Donald
Trump and that's what you're really
trying to do and Jane Mayer provides
solid evidence of that she writes
frankenz fall was stunningly Swift he
resigned only three weeks after Lee Ann
Sweden a conservative talk radio host
accused him of having forced an unwanted
kiss on her during a 2006 USO tour seven
more women followed with accusations
against Franken all of them centered on
inappropriate touches or kisses
half the accusers names have still not
become public although both Franken and
Sweden called for an independent
investigation into her charges
none took place this reticence reflects
the cultural moment in an era when
women's accusations of sexual
discrimination and harassment are
finally being taken
seriously after years of belittlement
and dismissal some see it as offensive
to subject accusers to scrutiny believe
women has become a credo of the me2
movement and sounds here like Jane Mayer
suddenly suddenly realizing the
downsides of all of this after helping
to pave a bunch of lies about Brett
Kavanaugh at its house Franken said he
understood that in such an atmosphere
the public might not be eager to hear
his grievances holding his head in his
hands he said I don't think people who
have been sexually assaulted and those
kind of things want to hear from people
who have been me to that their victims
yet he added being on the losing side of
the media movement which he fervently
supports has led him to spend time
thinking about such matters as due
process proportionality of punishments
and the consequences of internet fueled
outrage oh how odd oh how odd the
Democrats who found themselves on the
wrong side of their own standards are
now thinking about the downsides of the
standards they propagated against
Republicans again you want to know why
there's a mistrust it's because of stuff
like this if you really wanted us to
believe that you were sincere about your
feelings on this you would be condemning
people on your own side but you're not
are you you're not you're not telling
the truth about people on your own side
and then you expect Republicans are
going to play dead with you and this
isn't just with regard to matters of sex
minutes entire New Yorker piece goes on
and Jay Maher suggests that there is no
evidence of any of the accusations and
that the evidence is weak hilarious that
she wasn't willing to do that with Brett
Kavanaugh it feels a little strange it
feels a little bit like a double
standard but double standards are now
the only standards obviously and this is
not just true in the area of sexual
relations this is also true in the area
of race so the same prisoner's dilemma
applies we should all be able to condemn
racist incidents we should all be able
to condemn people more racist we should
all be able to say what just happened
here was a racist thing and it was
really bad so for example when Walter
Scott a black man was shot in the back
by a police officer in South Carolina
and then the police officer allegedly
planted a gun on Walter Scott's body
this appeared to be not only an instance
of police brutality but also of police
racism and pretty much everybody was on
board with that when Steve King said
something in defense of white
nationalism he was censured by his own
Republican colleagues in the house and
people like me maxed out to his
opponents in the Republican primaries
the likelihood that he emerges from
those primaries is now very low you're
supposed to condemn people on your own
side when they do bad things but again
there's a feeling that Democrats have
cheated on this
the Republicans are doing their best to
root out some of this stuff inside their
own party but they're not going to
condemn President Trump so long as the
Democratic Party refuses to call that
bigotry in its own midst and when
Democratic Party is meanwhile pushing
out hoaxes like jussie Smollett when you
have people on the Left who are pushing
out hoaxes like Jesse Smollett or people
who are suggesting that non-racial
shootings like the Ferguson killing of
Michael Brown that that is an actual
racist shooting it feels like a
malleable standard that is only wielded
to the benefit of one side and so a lot
of folks on the right are going well I'm
not going I just don't trust you to
uphold any sort of standard so I'm not
gonna give you honest answers about your
standard I don't answer to you I don't
answer to you has maybe become the sort
of modern-day battle cry of politics I
don't answer to you because what we all
used to answer to was not each other but
to a moral standard or at least that was
the idea maybe it was never true but it
certainly is not sure now certainly when
it comes to issues of race and there's a
feeling among Republicans and among
conservatives we're not gonna answer to
people who suggest that planting
cauliflower in New York City is
colonialist we're not going to answer to
people who suggest that it is a pure
form of racism to use the phrase Western
civilization we are not going to answer
to people who do not even acknowledge
the anti-semitism of folks ranging from
Al Sharpton to Louis Farrakhan we're not
going to answer to people who continue
to defend Ilhan Omar as the best among
us even though Ilhan NMR is a bigot and
raging anti-semite and Ayana Presley has
spouted racism and aoe's he rips into
the country regularly we're just not
going to answer to you well the latest
example of this happened over the
weekend so apparently there's a story
that ran wild over the course of
Saturday Friday night and Saturday as
woman aide Erika Thomas and she's a
black member of Georgia's House of
Representatives according to the New
York Times she said she had been the
target of verbal harassment and had been
told go back where you came from at a
grocery store near Atlanta on Friday in
a video she posted to her Facebook
account she suggested that a white man
had confronted her for having too many
items in the express checkout lane at a
Publix grocery store in Mableton Georgia
here's what it sounded like when she
talked about it I'm at the grocery store
and I'm in the tent out the outter says
ten items or less yes I have 15 items
but I'm not most pregnant
and I can't stand up for long his white
man comes up to me and says he says you
lazy son of a you need to go back
where you came from anything I could
just tell him please leave me alone
please if my child is just sitting right
there while we do it okay so in a second
I'm gonna explain what happened from
here suffice it to say it went viral and
mainly it went viral because that one
line go back where he came from why
because that echoes what President Trump
had suggested about the the squad the so
called squad so the idea is that this is
creating a viral wave of racism across
the country where white people are
telling black people go back where you
came from and that is the premise of
this entire story as we will see that is
not where this story ends up first I
think we can all agree that finding the
right pair of underwear isn't easy when
you find the right brand you stick with
it that's because if you get the wrong
brand they're falling apart or they're
sagging on you well I love my Tommy
John's why well Tommy John is the
revolutionary underwear brand that is
upgraded over 1 million lives including
mine it graces my tuchus right this
instant sold over 7 million pairs of
underwear 96% of their customers have
rated it 4 stars or more or more the
legs never ride up the waist bands never
roll down Tommy John is more than just
underwear they've also got products like
supersoft loungewear polo shirts and
apparel Tommy John is so sure you're
gonna love the fit and feel it's all
backed by their best pair you'll ever
wear or it's free guarantee that means
if you don't love your first pair you
will get a full refund Tommy John no
adjustment needed hurry over to Tommy
John comm slash Ben right now get 20%
off your first order again I love my
time you John underwear they're
supremely comfortable they're also
really durable like you can throw them
in the wash a bunch and they don't fall
apart
and they don't cost you an arm and a leg
either they are the best underwear on
the market as Tommy John comm slash Ben
for 20% off again that's 12 Tommy John
comm slash Ben get that 20% off deal
right now at Tommy John comm slash Ben
okay so that was her accusation Erika
Thomas this is Georgia Representative
said she was shocked that white men had
confronted her for having too many items
in the express checkout line said people
are getting really out of control with
this with this white privilege people
need to see the hate that is going on in
the country the hate is real
she says she was scared to go out of the
store because she thought the man was
gonna follow her or take out a gun you
just never know and then the man comes
out of the woodwork and he explains
himself as it turns out he is not white
he is Cuban he is not a Republican he's
a Democrat and he never actually said
this it's a man not to be rude like that
first words xx that's a sign which shows
it on the surveillance camera which I've
seen already point it to sign ten items
or less she she were rapes me after that
I don't remember exactly what she said
she said a few words I stated it well
you're selfish little bi TCH I did say
that that's all I said after that and I
walked out of public her Ward stating on
Twitter in her video saying I told her
she needs to go back where she came from
or untrue
I am Cuban I am NOT white ok and he's a
Democrat as it turns out she was she's
blatantly lying about and then she
backed down from her own statements who
she was interview about they said well I
don't really remember what he said
exactly he might not have said go back
home which of course is the entire
headline the entire headline like if
somebody curses somebody out in a Publix
checkout line that is not a racial
incident that's somebody being a jerk no
question that is not a racist incident
at all and if visited if the guy is
telling the truth and he said ma'am you
know you're in the Express line you got
15 items and she responded by yelling at
him then she was one who initiated the
conflict so we don't actually know the
answer to that at this point but she
herself has now admitted that he never
said go back where you came from which
again is the key to the story
considering the Democrats are pushing a
line right now that president Trump's
hatred and supposed bigotry and
xenophobia that this is causing a vast
wave of outcry across the United States
again no evidence that this guy's even a
Republican apparently he's a Cuban
Democrat but here she is acknowledging
that she didn't tell the truth go back
you know those types of words I don't
want to say he said go back to your
country or more back to where he came
from but he was making those types of
references is what I remember okay so
there she is backing off her original
tear filled explanation of what happened
so the guy who was apparently involved
in the incident
his name is Sparks he told the station
the local station that the episode had
started after he decided to say
something about the number of items in
her cart on the way out of the store
Thomas said in her Facebook video she
had between 15 and 20 items in her cart
in the express lane sparks said he was
buying three items sparks denied being
racist said he was Cuban he said he
acknowledged she had called her lazy but
said that had been the worst of his
comments he said this woman Miss Thomas
is playing the victim for political
purposes because she's a state
legislator I'm a Democrat I will vote
Democrat for the rest of my life so call
me whatever you want to believe for her
political purposes make it black white
brown whatever it's untrue miss Thomas
is a Democrat records about sparks is
party registration were not immediately
available on Sunday so this is buried at
the end of a piece from the New York
Times that is labeled quote the hate is
real black Georgia lawmaker says she was
berated at supermarket so there's the
New York Times putting out again what
appears to be a mythical story I hate
hoaxes in the New York Times at the top
of the article she openly acknowledges
that she didn't say that he didn't say
what she originally said he said but
nonetheless we were supposed to run with
the story why because there's part of a
narrative that is being built by the
media that the country is endemically
racist and cruel and horrible and
getting worse because President Trump
says bad things on Twitter okay so this
is all the lead-up to and part of the
background noise to the the hubbub over
President Trump's comments we'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about something we can all agree is
awesome that would be saving money honey
is a free tool that you can download to
your computer's browser while they shop
online
honey scans the internet for coupon
codes and other discounts then it
automatically applies the coupon with
the biggest savings to your cart at
checkout just like magic so you might
ask how do I know honey has my back well
I know it because I use honey but not
only that how do I know it really works
well not only did honey test over 1
billion promo codes last year it
actually applied 185 million 67,000 86
working codes to people's orders that is
a lot of real life savings I probably
saved hundreds if not thousands of
dollars using honey we do pretty much
all of our shopping online at this point
and honey helps out with virtually every
purchase there's really no reason not to
use honey it is free to use it's easy to
install on your computer in just two
clicks never overthink the promo code
box again get honey for free at join
honeycomb slash pen that's join honey
calm slash mint honey online savings
simplified there's no reason not to use
it because again it doesn't slow down
your computer it doesn't waste time it
saves you a bunch of time it'll save you
a bunch of money it saved me a lot of
money
join honey dot-com / Ben that's join
honey
come slash button okay so the backdrop
to all of this is that Republicans have
basically thrown up their middle finger
Trump was that middle finger in 2016 and
now when Democrats say well we're gonna
hold you to the standard that of calling
out racism why won't you call this stuff
out
Republicans say you won't call it out in
your own party you are willing to play
along with hate hoaxes you're willing to
pretend that justice Millette story was
anything more than highly non credible
from the start you were willing to run a
story in The New York Times called the
hate is real about a woman who
apparently backed down from her own
commentary so are we going to abide by
your standards of racism this ties back
into what I was saying last week right
last week I said when Republicans said
they agreed with Trump's tweet I really
don't believe that Republicans overall
agreed with Trump's tweet I think they
were answering pollsters who they think
are going to use their poll results as a
way to Club Trump I think that they have
decided many Republicans have decided
they don't they don't abide by the
standards that are held by the media
they've decided that the the media are
liars the commedia themselves don't
abide by these standards that Democrats
are changing and morphing the standards
of racism to meet circumstance they
won't condemn it in their own party when
Ayana Presley again it is amazing not
one question the entire week about iona
Presley saying black people can only be
black if they agree with her gay people
can only be gay if they agree with her
Muslim people can only be Muslim if they
agree with ohon omar for example no
blowback on that we still have yet to
hear it's incredible Ilhan Omar last
week proposed a fully anti-semitic
resolution comparing boycotting to
vesting and sanctioning from the State
of Israel to boycotting to vesting and
sanctioning Nazi Germany 1933 to 1941
she was not asked one single question of
which I am aware about this the entire
week neither was Nancy Pelosi and Nancy
Pelosi one month beforehand had stood up
at AIPAC and said the BDS was
anti-semitic not one question and then
you wonder why folks on the right are
unwilling to go out of their way to
condemn Trump not because they're making
a moral stand in favor of what Trump
said but because they don't trust you
and they're not going to engage in the
losing side of the prisoner's dilemma
where you set the standard or you don't
hold your own side to accounts and then
you demand that everybody else will
their side to account now it's not the
moral thing to do no it isn't the moral
thing to do would be to condemn bad
stuff wherever you see it I tried to do
that on the show last week I condemned
president Trump's tweets i condemned the
chance at the at the rally
in pretty strong language if you go back
and listen to it but that does not mean
that I don't understand why so many
Republican legislators are not willing
to go along with the media particularly
because the media again do play this
double-standard game it is also for the
de media have expanded the definition of
racism to me whatever they wanted to
meet on a variety of basis there's so
many situations in which the media calls
something racist that is not in fact
racist so Liz Cheney was appearing on
Face the Nation and while she was on
Face the Nation basically the whole
weekend was dedicated to the Sunday news
anchors trying to tar and feather
Republicans for not sufficiently
condemning Trump by the way all these
Republicans know that the next move
would then be for these people to ask
why they remain Republican so I don't
know why they don't vote for Joe Biden
if Trump is so bad why they don't vote
for impeachment and so they're just
heading off the media at the past and
they're saying no I don't actually agree
with your assessment of the case it is
also true that there is real controversy
over whether what Trump said was racist
or just xenophobic and that does make a
difference xenophobic is bad racist is
sort of the the killer app in American
politics right now if somebody is seen
as fully racist the way that Steve King
is now saying he has done if somebody is
seen as trafficking in xenophobia then
that is not the killer app because the
truth is that there is a fine line
between xenophobia and simple
unwillingness to admit particular
immigrants from particular cultures that
don't necessarily get along with the
United States meaning that the left has
conflated those two it's not really a
fine line but the left has crossed that
line and conflated those two so
xenophobia is the idea that all
foreigners are bad and just because
you're a foreigner you're bad it's bad
it's stupid it's ridiculous I mean
frankly I'm a libertarian on immigration
we're not for welfare and cultural
concerns and then there's what the media
do which is they label everything they
don't like on immigration xenophobic
we'll get to that in a second too
because as it turns out that may play
into the Democratic agenda and why
they're falling apart a little bit first
when I love in advertisers products so
much I buy one as a gift for my
relatives that means I really love it
that's the case with helix sleep
mattresses I love helix sleep so much
than when my sister had her wedding I
bought her husband and her a helix sleep
mattress why because these things are so
unbelievably comfortable helix sleep has
a quiz that takes just two minutes to
complete and matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you no matter how you
sleep on the side on your back hot
sleeper whatever it is helix can make
what your body needs just go to helix
sleep calm /bin take their two minutes
sleep quizzes they will match you to a
customized mattress that'll give you the
best sleep of your life four couples
helix can even split the mattress down
the middle providing individual support
needs and feel preferences for each side
they've got a 10 year warranty you get
to try it out for a hundred nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but I promise
you will because I know I've got one my
wife and I took the helix sleep quiz the
heat it's just a fantastic mattress
helix is now offering up to 125 bucks
off all mattress orders for our
listeners get up to 125 bucks off at
helix sleep comm slash Ben that's helix
sleep calm slash Ben for up to 125
dollars off your mattress order helix
sleep calm slash men go check them out
right now okay I have a lot more to talk
about with regard to president Trump's
comments and the and the double
standards and then we'll also give you
the update on Iran because that is a
disaster area first you need to go over
to daily wire calm right now and
subscribe for $9.99 a month or $99 a
year you can subscribe when you
subscribe with the annual you get this
the leftist here's hot or cold tumblr
overflowing on a regular basis it is a
magnificent piece of vessel work most
importantly you need to subscribe
because you help ensure that we can
continue to bring you the show when you
become part of the team not only do you
make sure that our producers get paid
but also you ensure that when the left
comes after us that we can continue to
bring us bring you the show because as
we say the left has no standards and
they're willing to do anything to
destroy opposition you can help protect
the shows that you love from opposition
by going ahead and and subscribe and
please go do so over its a Lee Weyer com
we're the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so Liz Cheney up hearing on the
sunday shows and Face the Nation
immediately starts browbeating her about
why she won't condemn President Trump as
racist why won't you just do it
I don't remember again a single question
to the Democrats about the the Ilhan
Omar BDS resolution over the weekend if
there was one please make me aware
because I was not aware of any of that
not a single question - Ayanna Presley
and they were interviewed last weekend
by CBS not a single question to her
about her racist comments but here Liz
Cheney make it why won't you just
condemn the President of the United
States for our viewing pleasure why
doesn't the president as a matter of
principle say unequivocally that
non-white Americans are just as American
as anyone else wasn't he put this to
rest well I think you've heard him say
that the chant was inappropriate we've
all said the chant was inappropriate I
think there's no media's Reata
I very Patriot I think the news media
really wants to make this about race you
just did it this isn't about race it's
not about gender it's not about religion
these members of the House of
Representatives more it's not just these
four it's also some of the candidates
who are running for president on the
Democratic side and fundamentally
believe in policies that are dangerous
for this nation okay and what Liz Cheney
is saying there is effectively correct I
mean Donald Trump did come out later the
wait later in the week and at least
disowned the send her back chance and
say that he didn't like them so at least
he scores one point there okay but
that's not gonna stop the media so Don
Lemon he's again going off Trump showed
his true colors this is what hit the
president is racist the president is
terrible Don Lemon has got nothing to
say when of course the the shoe is on
the other foot you can tell who is
honest and who is not by what they say
when the shoe is on the other foot and
Don Lemon has never been honest about
this stuff and that's why Republicans
are responding by saying that these
people can go stuff it well today the
President of the United States showing
his true colors after yesterday's failed
attempt to convince you that he didn't
like that send her back chant the
president doubling and tripling down on
his slurs against the congresswoman and
seeming to lose track of how many there
are going from four to three because he
doesn't like their politics okay so if
he doesn't like their politics then why
he's allowed to not like their
politics but apparently it's all about
well Todd lemon does not get to be the
man who police's racism he doesn't yeah
again last week I played it on the show
Don Lemon was talking about the wonders
of John McCain back in 2008 who was
calling John McCain a hateful racist the
New York Times has a piece today it's
very similar in New York Times has a
piece called Trump sets the terms on
racial division do Democrats know what
to do weird because for a long time it
was Barack Obama in the White House who
was suggesting that Trayvon Martin could
have been his son who is suggesting that
the community in Ferguson people would
never have made up these stories about a
police officer
it is the President of the United States
who's attacking Dallas police officers
all over the country and the police
system is endemically racist and it and
yet it was Trump who set the terms on
racial division only again this is not
what about ISM because I think that it's
very bad when from does this sort of
stuff I condemned it last week I will
continue to condemn it when he does
things that I disagree with morally but
it is a natural feature of American
politics that there's a reactionary side
which means that if the Left refuses to
be honest with with its own side the
right is not going to simply abide by
standards the left refuses so hold
meanwhile speaking of the left refusing
to hold by its own standards best story
of the weekend Bernie Sanders had to
respond to complaints from his staff
that he was not paying his staff $15 an
hour minimum wage now Sanders has been
pushing for a federally mandated $15
minimum wage and he wasn't paying his
own staffers that so here is what Bernie
Sanders did this is magical it really is
fantastic
I made a pay warders according to
Newsweek within his own 2020
presidential campaign Bernie Sanders
will limit the amount of time his
organizers can work to guarantee that no
one is making less than $15 per hour a
wage the senator has demanded should be
the federal minimum wait wait did Bernie
Sanders just discover economics did
Bernie Sanders just discover that like
the money doesn't grow on trees and that
if you pay people $15 an hour they have
to work fewer hours to have the same
wage base that you're paying right now
did Bernie Sanders just discover reality
it's gonna be very scary for him
anywhere except in the morning opens the
window and there's reservoir well does
this I couldn't just pay people a
billion dollars an hour I I'm at my own
campaign I will limit that working you
mean I will have them lose working hours
to save money on my
campaign business or let's do this wait
a second and then there's a heavenly
voice that descends on Bernie Sanders
and suddenly he starts voting like Paul
Ryan I mean it's just unbelievable it's
unbelievable it's by the way it's not
just Bernie Sanders who is now
acknowledging that his agenda is
completely unworkable in terms of his
own reality Cory Booker over the weekend
made the signal a true admission that
Medicare for all won't pass and is a
complete waste of time to push so here
is mr. Potato Head Cory Booker had Cory
Booker always bringing his angry eyes
here on CNN so Bernie Sanders Elizabeth
Warren they would do Medicare for all at
the beginning it get in the White House
that would be what they would do for you
the answer is Dana you and you and I
both know that even if we had 60 votes
in the Senate right now all the
Democrats in the Senate wouldn't even
support that this is about not letting
the perfect be the enemy of the good
I'm we're dealing with the country right
now that needs a lot more good so it's
Medicare strong next step of what no
would look Medicare for all is what we
should be going for but the first step
getting there has to be showing that we
can create a public option so yes it's
unrealistic is what he's saying so it's
funny to watch Democrats discover that
their entire platform is unrealistic by
the way this is apparently also at
around immigration a new democratic
think tank study is warning the
Democratic Party that their immigration
platform is a complete fail so according
to The Daily Beast new article they say
quote faced with combating the Trump
administration's hardline immigration
agenda in the arena of public opinion
Democrats have largely pointed to
reports of horrific detention centers
spiking in custody deaths of
undocumented immigrants and president
Trump's increasingly brazen attempts to
undermine the legal immigration system
but a new report from an influential
liberal think tank provided to The Daily
Beast posits that the party's decision
to cede the rule of law grounds to
Republicans creates the false dichotomy
of America as either a nation of
immigrants or a nation of laws making
the party and its candidates appear soft
on enforcement and potentially weakening
future attempts for humanitarian and
focused immigration reform yeah you
think you think that if you guys got too
radical that the American public might
in fact reject you so all the Democrats
are left with in the end is virtually
signaling they have unworkable policy
they have no standards by which to hold
anybody so instead they
do this pathetic virtue signaling so
here's a great example here's today's
pathetic virtue signaling from the
Democrats according to NBC News three
Democratic candidates have now added
their preferred pronouns to their
Twitter page now this is a perfect
example of something that says nothing
when it comes to public policy has
nothing to do with the political
conversation and is an absolute
pandering move in order to gain press
like this like everybody knows that
Elizabeth Warren is a woman but you and
everybody knows her position on
transgenderism and on the the so-called
Equality Act but in order for her to
pander and for her to virtue signal she
is going to put up on her Twitter page
her preferred pronouns and it's not just
her and wait I'm sure by the way this
will definitely win her Ohio Wisconsin
Pennsylvania and Michigan absolutely
this is the key issue I know that those
Michigan steel workers are very
concerned about Elizabeth Warren's
preferred pronouns according to John
Paul Brammer over at NBC News Elizabeth
Warren's bio on her official
presidential campaign Twitter page is
touting a new addition her pronouns
earlier this month her bio is updated to
u.s. senator former teacher and
candidate for president wife mom
grandmother and okie she hers official
campaign account so she's just going to
continue to propagate this nonsense
whereby you can't tell somebody sex by
their actual sex we have to ask them
what sex they are even though we know
perfectly well what sex they are NBC
knew she gets exactly what she's going
for from NBC News by the way NBC News
writes quote on the surface is just two
words not just on the surface also in
reality but the inclusion of she hers on
a front-runner candidates social media
profile is no small feat in the eyes of
LGBTQ advocates among the LGBTQ
community and its allies including
pronouns and social media profiles has
become increasingly common practice in
order to avoid misgendering and to
indicate solidarity with transgender and
non-binary people
isn't that nice so the Democrats have no
actual policy to run on instead they
just have an attitude and the attitude
is unearned moral superiority and
they're gonna continue to push that from
here to the end that's all this is about
Democrats want to establish unearned
moral superiority even though they don't
actually abide by any of the standards
they purport to abide by it's amazing
the same people so exactly the same
folks in the democratic party like
precisely the the Venn diagram is a
circle exactly this
people who are going to put transgender
and gender pronouns in their Twitter
biographies are the same people who will
suggest that Christians are not actually
Christians they're secretly brutal
racists and that they're using
Christianity in order to hide their
brutal racism and brutal bigotry and
brutal homophobia so we're supposed to
take everybody's evidence free
assessment of their own sex and gender
at face value to the point where we put
it on presidential profile candidates
and anybody who disagrees is a bigot and
at the same time if somebody says I'm a
Christian and therefore I hold that
certain types of behavior are sin or I
am a scientist and therefore I hold that
male is male and female is female really
that's just a cover for bigotry in the
end when you boil this whole double
standard thing down what you get to is
that the left has been doubting the
rights motives and calling the rights
motives into question for years and
years and years and years and now the
right doesn't trust the left and their
motives and so nobody trusts anybody's
motives and so it turns into just this
crap fight where the right is not going
to answer questions from the left
honestly the left is not going to answer
questions from the right honestly the
left is going to posture as morally
superior on the basis of apparently
nothing and the right is then going to
say well fine if you guys want to
posture is morally superior then we're
just gonna do what we want to do anyway
because you don't because you treat us
poorly that is the underlying dynamic of
American politics it's why Trump won in
2016 it's why right now he is certainly
a 50/50 shot to win the White House
again in 2020 okay meanwhile quick
update on the situation over in Iran so
the situation with regard to Iran is
becoming more and more volatile day by
day and there is a the newest story is
that the Iranians have declared that
they have 17 CIA spies
now usually when they declare they have
a CIA spy that is a lie usually they're
just making that up they arrest some
sort of civilian who happens to be from
the West or a political dissident and
they call them a CIA spy and then they
execute them but they are upping the
ante obviously also over the weekend the
Iranian Navy hijacked a British tanker
there's actual video of it it looked
like this you can see the you can see
the Iranian Navy they've got their their
helicopters over the tanker and the
British tanker couldn't stop them
parently they tried to stop it according
to the Sun dramatic footage shows about
balaclava clad Iranian commando
hijacking a British oil tanker in the
Strait of Hormuz video released
today captures the moment Tehran troops
abseil on to the Stena and pero with 23
crew on board last night Iran's
Revolutionary Guard launched a gunboat
and helicopter raid on its tanker which
is registered in the UK claiming it had
turned off its tracker and ignored
warnings which of course is a lie
Foreign Minister Jeremy Hunt said that
the ship has been seized in Omani waters
and clear contravention of international
law another vessel the mess star was
also intercepted and forced toward
Iranian territory and what appeared to
be a coordinated strike so what exactly
are the Iranians doing the Iranians are
attempting to force the Europeans and
the left in America to push President
Trump to re-enter the Iran nuclear deal
whereby the Iranians continue to reap
the benefits of monetary involvement in
the world economy they can use it for
terrorism they can use it for ballistic
missiles and they can develop nuclear
weapons up to a sort of set point that
set point is is basically a point of
stasis so the Iran nuclear deal was not
really a dismantling of the Iranian
nuclear program such that it would be
difficult for them to restart the
program it was a delay of their
completion of the program and so the
Iranians have said that they are
reversing that and now they are growing
more and more militant in an attempt to
basically force the West back to the
table in all of this javad zarif the
foreign minister was on with CNN's of
Fareed Zakaria that's basically what he
said although he said it knee in the
most untrue possible way because he is
of course the Iranian Foreign Minister
we defend our territory the United
States drone entered Iranian territory
entered Iranian airspace it was shot
down because even without entering
Iranian airspace it could spy over our
entire territory we will not tolerate
foreigners coming 6,000 miles from their
shores to our shores and threatening our
national sovereignty and stability do
you as a result think there could be a
war between the United States and Iran
well I can tell you that we will never
start the war we've never started the
war we will never start war but we will
defend ourselves and anybody who starts
the world will with Iran will not be the
one who ok effectively Iran has already
started a war and by the way the ron's
never starting a war would include you
know we have violating international law
by involving itself in international
conflict in Yemen
funding Hezbollah funding hamas funding
terrorist groups in argentina to bomb
jewish center
the Iranians are desperately attempting
to break the sanctions that's what's
happening right here and so the question
is who's gonna break first and whether
the Iranians really want to come back to
the table because the biggest problem
here is that the United States actually
has not hardened its own defenses in the
region so the ultimate the ultimate
threat of war which Iran would obviously
lose the Iranians feel that they can do
this with with a certain level of
impunity and get what they want out of
negotiations because the United States
is not sufficiently prepared to take the
sacrifices of a war which again I don't
want to fight a war Trump doesn't want
to fight a war nobody wants to fight a
war no one's interested in all of this
but that's why the Iranians are
thrashing around the best policy at this
point would be to flag some of these
tankers in the Gulf of Oman and in the
Straits of Hormuz they should flag the
tankers American and then they should
defend those tankers with American ships
and if the Iranians fire on those
tankers then America should just blow
their ships out of the water and should
be contained conflict it shouldn't be
something where it escalates and I don't
think around would want to escalate it
because beyond a certain point you start
killing American troops and then we do
have to put all of the mullahs in the
ground right at that point then the
Iranian regime is in trouble
they don't want that keeping this to a
low level conflict is manageable and
also keeps our on hand in it is true
that their funding of terrorist groups
has dropped precipitously because their
economic collapse has been for ordained
by the sanctions placed by the United
States okay time for some things I like
then some things that I hate so things
that I like today over the weekend I
read a great book on tennis called
levels of the game this is an older book
by John McPhee and it traces the the
tennis match between a player named
Bremner and Arthur Ashe one of the great
American tennis players in history it
really is more of an investigation of
the two men than it is an investigation
of tennis but it's beautifully written
is well worth reading if you're a tennis
fan at all you should go pick it up John
McPhee levels of the game okay other
things that I like so Megan McCain wrote
a beautiful column over the weekend I
think came out on Friday all about she
just suffered from a miscarriage and and
full disclosure I'm friends with with
Megan so this was you know obviously
it's got to be heartbreaking for her she
wrote what I think is a truly great and
useful piece about what it felt like to
have a miscarriage how it made her more
pro-life than ever how she understood
that it was a baby how losing the baby
did not not only did not change her
opinion on a
but it strengthened her opinion on
abortion she says even to this day the
subject of a miscarriage carries so much
cultural taboo miscarriages a pain too
often unacknowledged yet it is real and
what we have lost is real we feel sorrow
and we weep because our babies were real
they were conceived they lived fully
human and fully ours and then they died
we deserve the opportunity to speak
openly of them to share what they were
and to mourn more important they deserve
to be spoken of shared and mourn these
children shockingly smell shockingly
helpless entirely the work of our love
and our humanity our children we who
mourn are their mothers I you can't put
it better than that so well done Megan
McCain and I'm glad that she obviously
turned what is a tragic situation into a
cause for both inspiration and humanity
it's a great column you should check it
all out over at the New York Times okay
time for some things that I hate all
righty so Robert Muller is set to
testify this week Oh everybody's so
excited yet mothers gonna testify so
don't we already have like a 428 page
report on what Robert Muller thinks on
all of this didn't he give a very
cryptic 9 minute press conference in
which he explained exactly what he
thought of all of this apparently that's
not enough apparently Democrats are
still holding out hope that Robert
Muller is finally going to spill the
beans on Trump secretly he's been
holding a card in a bans the card that
he's been holding back is the card that
finally ends with the impeachment of
President Trump that apparently is what
Adam Schiff is saying he's saying Trump
should be in Titan maybe hope maybe
he'll have to leave office and then
we'll indict him funny how Schiff moved
from we should impeach him to will
indict him after he leaves office if he
really thinks Trump is indictable why is
he not pushing for impeachment that
would be the open question here is Adam
Chef for as president Trump calls him
oddly and strangely pencil Mac here is a
pencil neck chef according to President
Trump you know from Bob Muller that he
felt and the Justice Department feels
bound by this Office of Legal Counsel
opinion that you can't indict a sitting
president but he is a essentially
unindicted co-conspirator he's been
identified as an individual one as the
person who directed Michael Cohen to
commit this fraudulent campaign scheme
he is not above the law he may have a
temporary reprieve while he occupies
that office but I think the Justice
Department will have to seriously
consider reopening the case if that's
what it requires and indict him when he
leaves office oh well is that what's
to happen so why are you not calling for
impeachment if it's so clear-cut if it
turns out that the president is gonna be
prosecuted by the SDN why quietly last
week by the way the SDN why did drop
certain charges against Trump in the
state of New York drop certain charges
against the Trump Organization why
exactly are they so confident after
years of pitching into the narrative
that Trump was going to fall on the
mobile reporter came out the Milan
report comes out nothing happens and
suddenly they're back doing the same
routine that we're doing two weeks ago
or ten or eight weeks ago rather here's
jury natal are doing the same thing
Jerry Nadler from from New York he says
well the mobile report shows that Trump
is impeachable really so where's your
motion to impeach where is it I'm
missing it here's Chris Wallace asking
in this what you just said he's violated
the law six ways from Sunday if he
weren't the president he'd be indicted
you've read the 448 page report do you
believe the president is guilty of high
crimes and misdemeanors the marker for
impeachment by the house I think there
is very substantial well the report
presents very substantial evidence that
the president is guilty of high crimes
and misdemeanors and we have to present
that or that malla present those facts
to the American people and then see
where we go from there because the
administration must be held accountable
and no president can be can be above the
law okay so there is nothing in the
mellah report that suggests that he
believes that a prosecutable crime
prosecutable crime occurred now lots of
activity may have occurred that was
gross or yucky or nefarious we went
through it at the time I mean I read
every page of the report I summarized it
for you on three or four separate days
when the report came out there was
nothing in there that was actually
prosecutable now what Muller did is
something that is pretty weaselly
actually instead of him simply saying I
don't recommend prosecution because it's
not prosecutable and said he handed the
report to William Barr who said exactly
that and then Muller went out and did a
presser in which he said if we could
have exonerated the president then we
would have it wasn't your job to
exonerate the president it was your job
to determine whether he was prosecutable
that was not a good act of prosecution
by Muller Miller knows better what that
report basically suggested is that
Muller wants Congress to impeach Trump
but he doesn't believe that President
Trump could be convicted in a court of
law that's really what the Mobil report
said and it wasn't really about the DOJ
not being able to prosecute President
Trump despite the demo
trying to paint it that way unless
William bar was lying openly which would
be cause for great concern for me and
others obviously unless the Attorney
General was lying openly Bob Muller told
him explicitly that he was not failing
to recommend prosecution simply because
of the DOJ regulations so Jerry Nadler
said at the point of Muller's testimony
was so the American people could quote
hear directly from him about what his
investigation found he says quote the
president and the Attorney General and
others have spent the last few months
systematically lying to the American
people about what the investigation
found they've said that it contained no
clue that it found no collusion that had
found it no obstruction that it
exonerated the president all three of
those statements are absolute lies well
no the first one did find no collusion
it certainly found no conspiracy or any
prosecutable crime on obstruction the
question is whether the president
fulminating to his advisers about how
much he hated Robert Muller and wanted
him to go or fulminating about Jeff
sessions and talking about firing him
whether number one it can be obstruction
to fire a member of the executive branch
if that constitutes obstruction in and
of itself probably not on a technical
level or to weather him fulminating
about and then not doing it even
constitutes obstruction as far as it
exonerating the president I said at the
time that the report did not exonerate
the President on obstruction it did not
exonerate the president with regards to
his behavior inside the administration
but that does not mean it's prosecutable
so lots of lots of charges are
investigated by the police and they are
and they are not found to be exonerating
but they're not prosecutable asked about
questions republicans lawmakers plan to
ask Nadler said if Republicans want to
talk about the relevancy of the Russia
probes origins let them waste their time
he says what's before the American
people now is the conduct of this
president and what Muller found about
the conduct of this president and where
we go from here so Democrats still
holding out that last desperate hope
that perhaps Muller will save them from
the consequences of three years of
declaring that all of this is going to
come to a head and end with Trump's
impeachment not going to happen
meanwhile in what is I think more
shocking news real clear investigations
has a piece today talking about
Inspector General Michael Horowitz his
upcoming report so Michael Horowitz has
an upcoming report on the origins of the
Russia story and Rilke investigations
does so
interesting stuff Paul Sperry is the
reporter over there he talks about what
exactly Horowitz is going to find here's
what he says it is one of the most
enduring and consequential mysteries of
the Trump Russia investigation
why did former FBI director James Comey
refuse to say publicly what he was
telling President Trump in private the
Trump was not the target of an ongoing
probe that refusal ignited a chain of
events that has consumed Washington for
more than two years including commis
firing by Trump the appointment of
special counsel Robert Muller and
ongoing claims that Trump obstructed
justice now an answer is emerging
sources tell real clear investigations
that Justice Department Inspector
General Michael Horowitz will soon file
a report with evidence indicating that
Comey was misleading the president even
as he repeatedly assured Trump that he
was not a target
the former director was secretly trying
to build a conspiracy case against the
president while times acting as an
investigative agent to US officials this
is according again to real clear
investigations to US officials briefed
on the Inspector General's investigation
of possible FBI misconduct said that
Comey was essentially running a covert
op against the president starting with a
private defensive briefing he gave Trump
just weeks before his inauguration
they said that Horowitz has examined
high-level FBI text messages and other
communications indicating that Comey was
actually conducting a
counterintelligence assessments of Trump
during that January 2017 meeting in New
York now the difference between counter
intelligence assessments and criminal
assessments is that if it were criminal
then you'd actually have to have
warrants for all of this that are
different from FISA warrants that you do
it you'd actually have to show evidence
of criminality counterintelligence just
means that you suspect that the Russians
are interfering and that as part of that
chain you are now investigating the
people on the other side and that's a
lower bar that Comey would have to clear
in addition to taking notes of his
meetings and phone calls with from to
the official FBI case file
Comey had an agent inside the White
House who reported back to FBI
headquarters about Trump and his aides
according to other officials familiar
with the matter apparently he was using
what a spy inside the White House
reporting back to the FBI about the
incoming president and his aides based
on what evidence
exactly this is having the having the
head of the FBI investigating the
elected president of the United States
the president-elect
that's pretty ugly stuff obviously
especially if you don't come up with
good although
homie took many actions on his own he
was not working in isolation one focus
of Horowitz his inquiry is the private
January 6 the 2017 briefing that Comey
gave the president-elect in New York
about material in the Democratic
commissioned dossier compiled by exit
British intelligence officer Christopher
Steele reports of that meeting were used
at days later by BuzzFeed CNN and other
outlets as a news hook for reporting on
the dossiers lascivious and
unsubstantiated claims so there are
accusations by among others Molly
Hemingway over at the Federalist at the
time at the reason that Comey briefed
Trump on the dossier was specifically so
that CNN could then report that Comey
had braved Trump on the dossier and then
you could see BuzzFeed got a Willian
what was the dossier that he was briefed
on here it is P tape it basically was an
excuse set up by Comey and other members
of the FBI in order to create a
rationale for BuzzFeed to run the
dossier in the first place now again
there are a few links in that chain that
have yet to be substantiated
communications for example between Comey
or members of the FBI and members of the
press right now that has yet to be
substantiated but this has always been a
weird outstanding question why exactly
would Comey brief Trump on the dossier
that was unsubstantiated and had no
impact on the actual investigation
according to Democrats right the steel
dossier supposedly was not the basis
really for FISA warrants or for the
opening of the investigation in the
first place because if it were then it
would look kind of nefarious that
Hillary Clinton's campaign created the
dossier with Christopher Steele then
handed it over to Barack Obama's FBI
which initiated an investigation against
her political opponents in the 2016
campaign right that starts to look an
awful lot like a conspiracy between the
Obama DOJ and FBI and the Hillary
Clinton campaign and starts to look
really really bad so there are a lot of
open questions here homies meeting with
Trump took place one day after the FBI
director met in the Oval Office with
President Obama and Vice President Joe
Biden to discuss how to brief Trump a
meeting attended by the NSA Susan Rice
Homeland Security Secretary jeh Johnson
Deputy Attorney General Sally Yates and
national intelligence director James
clapper who would soon go work for CNN
Comey denied having an accounts or
intelligence case file open on Trump
though he qualified the denial by adding
this was true only in the literal sense
he also twice tonight investigating
Trump under oath in congressional
testimony so depending on what Horowitz
finds there could be a perjury charge
here former federal prosecutor Andrew
McCarthy
who's written extensively on all of this
said that just because the president's
name was not put on a file or a
surveillance warrant does not mean that
the Comey FBI was not investigating him
they were hoping to surveil him
incidentally and they were trying to
make a case on him said McCarthy the
real reason Comey did not want to repeat
publicly the assurance he made to trump
privately is that the assurance was
misleading the FBI strung Trump along
telling him he was not a subject while
structuring the investigation in
accordance with the reality that Trump
was actually the main suspect this of
course is disputed by other folks former
FBI counterintelligence agent and lawyer
Marc walk said that the FBI lacked legal
grounds to treat Trump as a suspect a no
probable cause they were scrambling to
come up with anything to hang a hat on
but they'd found nothing so it's unclear
why exactly this investigation became
such a a massive massive thing given the
slim read upon which it was originally
based apparently and that remains the
subject of Michael Horowitz his
investigation so commis conduct is
clearly going to come up for all sorts
of controversy according to Paul Sperry
over real clear investigations at the
time Comey was personally scrutinizing
the president during meetings in the
White House and phone conversations from
the FBI he had an agent inside the White
House working on the Russia
investigation he reported back to FBI
headquarters about Trump and his aides
the agent was named Anthony Ferrante he
specialized in cybercrime he left the
White House had around the same time
Comey was fired and soon joined a
security consulting firm where he
contracted with BuzzFeed to lead the
news sites efforts to verify the seal
dossier in connection with a defamation
lawsuit knowledgeable sources inside the
Trump White House say that Kovac armed
Comey carved out an extraordinary new
position for Ferrante which allowed for
him to remain on reserve status at the
FBI while working in the White House as
a cyber security adviser so I think this
report was supposed to drop July so we
should find out in very short order what
exactly Michael Horowitz has to say
about the initiation of the Russia
investigation which of course is the
other side of the coin in terms of the
Muller investigation why did this thing
start why was so many resources placed
into it was it nefariously begun with an
attempt to get President Trump because
he was Hillary Clinton's chief
antagonist and opponent in 2016 so we
will bring you all of the developments
there as this continues all righty so
we'll be back here a little bit later
today we'll have two additional hours of
programming and if you don't get that
then go to daily wire.com subscribing
get that every single day or we'll see
you here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show at every level of
society people are being silenced and
controlled by corporate leftists
overseers that's why when Trump speaks
and acts without fear and sometimes
without thinking it sounds to us like
freedom that's what this administration
is about and that's what the next
election will be about - we'll talk
about it on the Andrew Klavan show